hello everybody and welcome to part 2 of
let's play amnesia the Dark Descent now
I've noticed that there are a lot of
creepy noises going around all over the
place but I will not let that deter me
I'm a rock unshakable just dark Oh
chemistry pot ah
third attempt the blood experiment
aakriti aqua Fortis that's what he said
calamine lotion or payment coupe right
that's the thing that he was talking
about highly acidic grooves in practical
detergent doing some laundry very
violent laundry um losing hope very cool
awesome ah box tinderbox whoa one day
terrible things but he takes comfort of
you I weep for them they lust for power
I crave fair judgement and safe return
got a level-headed guy
tinderbox empty my air wheel empty
awesome bottles bottles why is
everything shaking seriously why is
twice things shaking right here it's not
shaking here oh whoa
shaking it okay oh uh huh lack of a
chimney that seems important huh
stained by the fumes moving to the wine
cellar
Leidy lady lady lady Bunsen burner book
twisty twisty ah four different
chemicals are needed I need to find some
chemicals are they on the shelves yes
yes maybe time methyl delirium in Tim
minam Kateri applica anibus cannabis hey
that's interesting stuff
pile of rotting whatever all right
barrels boxes snake Oh
roaches long up it's much brighter in
here negligible torches very nice
entrance hall moving on
alright [ __ ] cellar
the wine cellar the place where he put
all the people I'm gonna assume that
everyone in this castle is bad I'm not
going down there huh no sir
it's almost always something behind a
staircase sunlight I like it
ooh so bright Oh barely see board it up
door to the hoozy whoa ah budge I can
read
rocks or two can't see all right more
daylight keep it movin tabularium like
tabula rasa tahn oh ah
I'm smart I can connect to words loading
loading loading loading maybe I should
tell a story in loading times
normally my criticals faster than this
but I'm trying to compile video at the
same time
you heard that too right crazy
nope 16th May 1839 years the unflinching
African Sun has continued to plague our
expedition unflinching making it
impossible to dig until dusk how
professor her emerge to find the
location in these father claims our
nothingness mass remains a mystery nah
I'm assuming that you're all out the
tube again not into spooning its silicon
but in paraná and you're gonna think I'm
an [ __ ] but I'm gonna skip these if
you want to read I'm sorry
I'm gonna strength right but I can later
that evening we uncovered a passage
beneath the 200 other leading dark cold
night
got it tomorrow tomorrow burial chamber
yield screw London British Museum reach
London bury a fare Mayfield no matter
what the professor is Daniel from me
that's a chair yeah
like
great rewards hiding none of these
drawers stupid boys they're up it's done
I'm a lantern
ooh-ah-ha full attention Alexander
burger burger three years freedom
Alexander brennenburg services Prussian
Prussian order the black eagle may no
man break this seal oops
[ __ ] sorry about that Wilhelm how so
Gary
my bad yeah all the way chair
I said get out of a chair ah it's not
good at this new tinderbox Hey oh [ __ ]
ah hey arrived
Sonlight me for this do deal
[ __ ]
it sounded like a constipated goat
I'm guessing
all right nothing nothing nothing this
very exciting game I'm sure your own
will to watch it
no 17th of May ah 1830 and shrivel my
hand memory will fail he already has
Daniel today Maxum men and ventured the
darn faintly passage man superstitious
are you loudly screams language in the
monasteries strength his young age on
the ground yelled man to you the crudely
food table love live it up lo great
milestones no bit older than the fourth
century lazy susan boyle scrapped it
sounds bad man
alright I'm coming for you mu see dark
dark dark weebly the terrace oh whoa -
thank you
I know my Latin consignee all a book
fell yeah I was scary
here's the piano it's not hard so
there's a
gone right righty-ho
all right I know my Latin gosh I'm gonna
be such a jerk
ya know ya know whoa you
something's not right here Oh Moo see
it's not a constipated goat that is a
constipated moose Lucy blood Oh moose he
fell and hurt himself
he's crying in pain more roaches God is
placed problem yeah no so we're playing
you ah what they won't be able to sit oh
mylanta No
oh I know what the menu button is now
it's tab all right lantern oil oil oil
oil oil all right full heart good head
his pound a handshake that does seem
good whatever
schematic for something more schematics
for something another schematic for
something wow that was really a belay ah
but of course I bet I'm tracking him
aren't I
yes whoa whoa hey [ __ ]
okay yeah I'll take a nap seems like
it's good idea May 1839 after pounding
the unforgiving stone war for what
seemed like an eternity and realized it
was hopeless I was trapped
sounds bad nailed to the ground gasping
for air trying to focus that's when I
saw a faint blue shimmer Mike weakened
body yeah to carry but I managed to push
myself toward Vietnam no way moving this
way it was waiting for me and closed in
dark nothing I don't looking up myself
drawn to the mystic light yeah all right
fine
good day read out closely
wow it's like a fail Oh escaped my
fingers began to spark brightly and
spirit me away I'm looking a lien
memories of spiraling towers endless
deserts and impossible geometry if the
next you say member is the grating sound
of stone being lifted the voices of the
Arab pulling me to safety grasped firmly
in my hands was the broken pieces I
think most acutely a relic then he
rubbed the lamp and got three wishes how
about that well your piano someone
playing that piano I hope you enjoyed
not sitting down oh yeah I'm trying yeah
oh yeah yeah oh yeah Roch Roch
like the looks of this GU box ah ah
again with the piano get over yourself
much of the castle is old that hasn't
been tempted to for centuries and
there's a ghost pianists it won't take
long until things start falling apart
which is fine time anyway let's do what
we can
there isn't much to not about wars we
should reinforce weak structures the
ground will tremble and there's a risk
everything will cave in on us especially
downstairs yeah downstairs well I don't
want to go in there not that I'm scared
or anything difference working on it's
just that I don't like basements radon
you know it's poisonous give you cancer
rayon no rayon some folks radon
all right who's there
there oh you closed the lid on it did
you ha ha ha
booyakasha Wow I am strong all right I
gotta stop this here I'll catch you in
part three